CONVICTED, ANDRE IS BACK WITH ME
AND ANDRE, OBVIOUSLY DEEPLY
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
HOW DID YOU FIND OUT THAT YOU'RE
ON RUSSIA'S WANTED LIST?
>> WELL, HELLO.
I GOT SEVERAL STRANGE MESSAGES
FROM MY BANK IN MOSCOW TELLING
ME THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN, I OWE
SOMETHING LIKE $80,000 AND
75,000 EUROS AND I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT UNTIL I GOT
ANOTHER MESSAGE FROM ANOTHER
BANK WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
NOW I FACE A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION WITH A NUMBER OF
THE CASE AND THEN, I TOOK SOME
HOURS TO WORK OUT AND TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ACTUALLY, WHILE
INVESTIGATING THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE, APPEARS
TO SPREAD FAKE NEWS ABOUT THE
WAR.
>> AND YOU SHARE WITH US THE
DOCUMENTS THAT RUSSIA'S
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE
PRESENTED TO THE COURT SO YOU
SHARED WITH US, THEY LAY OUT
THEIR CHARGES AGAINST YOU.
THEY'RE PUNISHABLE, ANDRE, UP
TO, GOING TO PRISON, AND WHAT
PUTIN HAS WANTED TO SILENCE HIS
DISSENTERS, HE HAS FOUND A WAY
TO DO SO.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE NOT IN
MOSCOW RIGHT NOW, BUT ARE YOU
WORRIED THAT YOUR FREEDOM OR,
FRANKLY, ANDRE, YOUR LIFE, IS
NOW IN DANGER?
>> WELL, I UNDERSTAND THAT I
CANNOT TRAVEL TO CERTAIN
COUNTRIES WHICH ARE, WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND MY FAMILY BACK
IN MOSCOW IS A POTENTIAL TARGET
AND WE ALREADY SEE SOME MOVES IN
THIS DIRECTION AND OBVIOUSLY,
HAS THE IDEA OF THE FSB, BECAUSE
IT IS THE FSB WHICH IS BEHIND
THIS INVESTIGATION, IS TO STOP
ME FROM REPORTING, TRY TO
UNDERSTAND, BUT BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR 23 YEARS AND
THE VERY FIRST TIME I WAS
INVESTIGATED BY THE FSB WAS
EXACTLY 20 YEARS AGO SO I SORT
OF, I UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> ANDRE, YOU KNOW, THE REASON
THEY ARE TARGETING YOU AND GOING
AFTER YOU RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE
OF YOUR REPORTING.
YOU'VE DONE SOME INCREDIBLE
REPORTING ON THE FSB, WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON IN THIS WAR
SPECIFICALLY, ON PUTIN, HIS
STRATEGY, WHAT'S GOING ON IN HIS
INNER CIRCLE, ON THE, YOU KNOW,
FSB MEMBERS AND, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN DETAINED,
HOUSE ARRESTS, ALL OF THIS.
NOW I KNOW YOU'RE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT TACTICS, NEW TACTICS THE
FSB IS USING.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THAT?
>> YEAH, WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THAT
THE KREMLIN AS FSB IS MOVING
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO ALREADY LEFT
THE COUNTRY.
I'M NOT THE ONLY JOURNALIST
TARGETED NOW BY THE RUSSIAN
AUTHORITIES AND ALL OF US ARE
NOW ABROAD, SO THE OBVIOUS,
WELL, OBJECTIVE OF THE RUSSIAN
AUTHORITIES IS TO FIND A WAY HOW
TO GET US BACK OR TO SILENCE US
AND WE ALREADY KNOW THAT AT
LEAST SEVERAL FAMILIES OF PEOPLE
WHO LEFT VISITED BY T